grazie luca a me dispiace venire dopo
ersilia che ho ascoltato con grande
interesse perché vi porto delle cose di
grande fascino infinitamente grande alle
piccolezze quotidiani dei nostri tempi
cioè alla politica alla società che la
domanda di fondo nel mio intervento e se
esiste un o una democrazia digitale e se
il mondo digitale farà bene alla nostra
democrazia
allora la riflessione che vi propongo
ruota intorno a due differenti concetti
quella di democrazia diretta è quello di
democrazia partecipata o partecipativa e
in generale nel fatto che va sotto il
nome di civismo politico allora la rete
ci offre una quantità rilevante di
esperimenti di cosiddetto e government e
di coinvolgimento diretto dei cittadini
pensate solo al caso islandese cioè la
consultazione permanente dell'elettore
amministrato e poi alla lunga casistica
veramente lunga e che incoraggiante di
comuni che testano la qualità dei loro
servizi riprogrammano e coinvolgono
nella gestione singoli o gruppi si
realizzano così efficienze e si migliora
la condizione di vita di città ed i
territori
con un'avvertenza però non sempre la
maggioranza ha ragione e la tutela dei
diritti deboli e delle minoranze non può
essere lasciata all'arbitrio della
vecchia allora la trappola dell'egoismo
e il limite della democrazia diretta per
democrazia diretta in rete e non la
svizzera ne è un esempio il popolo ha
votato l'anno scorso ve lo ricorderete
contro gli immigrati ma poi il governo
dopo il voto inequivocabile dei
cittadini svizzeri non sa più come fare
si accorge per esempio che il costo
della realizzazione pratica di quello
che è stato votato
il 9 febbraio del 2014 cioè la
rinegoziazione di tutti gli accordi con
l'unione europea e un costo di
gigantesco e non assolutamente valutato
dagli elettori quindi sottoporre tutto a
un referendum non fa una democrazia
matura
un altro scoglio difficilmente
superabile
come evitare per esempio che nelle
consultazioni in rete e voi e
partecipate tutti i giorni minoranze
organizzate e generalmente supposizioni
estreme abbiano la meglio sull'opinione
della maggioranza che è meno reattiva
che più tranquilla la piattaforma per
esempio che voi conoscerete change.org è
straordinariamente utile ma come ci
comportiamo davanti a casi di moderno
ostracismo sull'onda emotiva degli
avvenimenti come garantire i diritti
elementari la lapidazione e residuo di
barbarie medievale ma un uso più moderno
e multimediale non la rende di per sé
meno crudele e feroce insomma la
democrazia diretta in rete va maneggiata
con estrema cura lo stesso movimento 5
stelle nella selezione dei candidati
alle prossime amministrative ha
preferito primarie classiche anziché
affidarsi alla consultazione via web
le primarie sono manipolabili
ma non del tutto imprevedibili come i
sondaggi e rete così da trasparenza e ho
sempre un valore la trasparenza a questa
è una domanda che ci poniamo spesso
certamente un valore in un paese opaco
come il nostro lo è nella maniera più
assoluta però assistere in streaming a
un dibattito parlamentare
certamente fa crescere la partecipazione
però è necessario per esempio a seguire
in diretta una riunione riservata in cui
si deve raggiungere un compromesso per
esempio esaltare la trasparenza la
bentham con il suo panopticon finisce
spesso per trasformare i protagonisti in
attori peraltro scarsi come atto
qui che recitano un copione allora io
non credo che oggi per esempio 5 stelle
del nostro paese ripeterebbero la farsa
degli incontri in streaming con le altre
forze politiche non è stata una
trasparenza utile è stata una
trasparenza dell'osa allora la
democrazia partecipata e partecipativa
può essere invece uno strumento
formidabile e questo il messaggio di
fondo che vorrei darvi perché interpreta
la libertà esalta i diritti da
consapevolezza dei doveri e può
coinvolgere nel modo migliore i
cittadini della gestione delle risorse
scarse mettendoli costantemente di
fronte a scelte e anche la valutazione
di quelli che sono i costi opportunità i
costi alternativi
il nostro paese peraltro ne ha più
bisogno di altri visto che la democrazia
rappresentativa è ridotta ma questa è
una mia opinione personale con le ultime
riforme a una semplice funzione i
cittadini un circolo quasi più e loro
rappresentanti
e questo secondo me alimenta
l'astensionismo al populismo e quelle
forme di semplificazione estrema che
sono un tratto inestinguibile della
multimedialità
avevo un uso corretto della rete con
piattaforme cv che dà voce e coscienza
ai cittadini ma per fare questo sono
necessarie alcune cose non sono non si
può risolvere tutto con delle app di
condivisione e indispensabile una
pedagogia della rete che solo voi io
ritengo voi che rappresentate
l'avanguardia del mondo digitale potete
avviare quindi un educazione profonda
aperta e avanzata e soprattutto la
crescita di una cultura digitale della
partecipazione del rispetto che ci
consenta di combattere anche il cinismo
della tecnologia perché questo è un
aspetto che vorrei proporvi entusiasmo
con contagioso che coloro che credono
nel dogma dell'infallibilità digitale è
per certi versi un'altra ideologie
totalitarie
e di questo noi ci dobbiamo guardare ci
dobbiamo opporre per esempio il problema
dell'anonimato e anche della gigantesca
attrazione se ne parla veramente poco
quella gigantesca attrazione distruttiva
che per esempio il deep web rappresenta
spesse volte le facciamo finta che non
esista invece c'è e va comunque regolata
allora la democrazia della rete risiede
più coscienza e responsabilità da parte
dei suoi interpreti
io credo che sia più importante
un'autoregolamentazione una coscienza
del mezzo piuttosto che le regole codici
di rieti che peraltro sono difficilmente
applicabile noi abbiamo ogni giorno
dimostrazione di come crescano in rete
esempi di nuovo civismo uno
straordinario episodio per esempio di
intelligenza collettiva lo abbiamo visto
alcuni giorni fa con il fenomeno dei
gattini di plustek russell lockdown in
chiave anti terrorismo e avete visto
dopo quello che è successo il 13
novembre a parigi come sia cresciuto
questo civismo in rete
ciò intelligenza collettiva molto forte
che cresce e da questa l'intelligenza
collettiva dobbiamo costruire una
democrazia partecipata anno del civismo
della rete è l'antidoto anche alla crisi
dei partiti e delle rappresentanze
intermedie ma abbiamo il grande problema
di come trasformare il civismo delle
comunità virtuale il senso di
responsabilità nel mondo reale come
creature per esempio connessioni globali
con dialogo e partecipazione anche con
il nostro vicino con il nostro prossimo
non si può sostenere semplicemente che
l'innovazione avanza e speriamo noi che
avanzi sempre di più è che la società
seguirà perché sarà inevitabile che la
società seguirà quindi come si diceva un
tempo
l'intendenza seguirà non è così facile
perché quale società seguirà questa
innovazione una siccità dei cittadini o
la società di sudditi o peggio di te all
io sono convinto che l'ecologia della
rete sia indispensabile per una società
avanzata libera e responsabile
culmine l'ecologia della terra di cui si
discuterà speriamo non invano a pochi
giorni con i lavori della coop 21 della
prossima conferenza di parigi grazie di
avermi ascoltato